Hey it's me Destin welcome back to Smarter Every Day. Yep, that's a rainbow.
and ah.. yep, that's Machu Picchu.
And of course, that's a lama. So the reason I haven't uploaded a video
lately is because I'm down in Peru on multiple adventures, and
we've got Jeff, a high resolution photography expert from PeruNature.com,
Gordon, he's the guy that does the sound for Smarter Every Day,
and we have very little internet, so it's time to leave cause it's raining now
but we're gonna go try to figure out how to upload this video.
Also if you have any suggestions for what I should do next week with a high speed video
camera in the jungle, the Amazon rainforest, let me know via SmarterYouTube
you can tweet me, or a facebook message. That's it.
You're getting Smarter Every Day. Stay tuned.